wie schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live wirst du geimpft ja oder nein wer
von uns hätte mal gedacht dass das nur
frage ist die unseren alltag bestimmt
und sogar ein streit und diskussionen
ändert aber so weit sind wir inzwischen
die gesetze gesellschaft wirkt ziemlich
gespalten und die einen verstehen nicht
wenn man es macht und die anderen
verstehen nicht wenn man es lässt und
darüber soll es heute geben wir wollen
uns mit dieser frage beschäftigen denn
auch wenn die mehrheit in deutschland
geimpft ist dann gibt es immer noch
viele die sagen oder impfung nein danke
und wir wollen heute wissen was sind die
gründe dafür und da werde ich sprechen
mit meiner kollegin die zdf-journalistin
patricia schäfer die gemeinsam mit
sibylle bassler eine zdfzoom doko
gemacht hat die heute abend auch im
fernsehen läuft aber natürlich jetzt
schon in der mediathek zu sehen ist sie
haben die frage gestellt geimpft oder
nicht kleine frage große sprengkraft und
was das mit unserer gesellschaft macht
das hören wir von dem sozialpsychologe
andreas zick von der universität
bielefeld und alle fragen zur corona
impfung die ihr habt die können wir am
ende stellen anolis ulrike protzer von
der technischen universität münchen sie
es virologin und wird all unsere fragen
dazu beantworten und wenn ihr fragen
oder kommentare habt dann könnt ihr die
jederzeit gerne direkt in den stream
schreiben oder jetzt hier an die
eingeblendete adresse
und bevor wir mit patricia schäfer einer
der autoren der zdf doku sprechen
schauen wir auch mal ganz kurz rein und
hören was da jemand sagt der sich nicht
gegen korona impfen lassen möchte
das war nicht von anfang an aber mit
meiner meinung nach einer reihe von
fragwürdigen politischen erlassenen
verordnungen freut sich dass immer mehr
verfestigt und jetzt ist eigentlich der
pieks da gar nicht mal so das thema aus
und dann einfach ich will nicht teil
dieses systems trend es kann nicht sein
dass repression und ausgrenzung dass das
richtig ist
die meisten seien eingeschüchtert seit
dieser kimmig geschichte einfach weil
die breite öffentlichkeit so über den
hergefallen ist vorher hat man das
gefühl dass vielleicht die ungeimpften
eigene stimme kriegen könnten und das
passiert jetzt nicht mehr man würde
einseitig abgestempelt haben die
ungeimpften ist schuld an allem
wenn wir jetzt die möglichkeit mit einer
der beiden autorinnen zu sprechen
patricia schäfer schön dass du heute
darf ist vielen dank aber lisa habe es
gerade gehört die ungeimpften sind an
allem schuld das war jetzt ein satz der
gefallen ist was war noch so ein
bisschen das gefühl dass ihr mitbekommen
habt von den menschen mit denen er
gesprochen hat die eben nicht geimpft
entstand jetzt
also es ist was sich durch zieht es dass
sie das gefühl haben sie stehen auf
einer seite des grabens und es gibt
einen graben es gibt verschiedene gründe
warum man sich gegen eine impfung
entscheidet in unserer doku ging es uns
eigentlich mehr darum wie diskutieren
wir warum streiten wir so heftig immer
noch anderthalb jahre später über über
corona und schreibt mir so heftig über
die impfung die gründe sind sehr
vielfältig also mann
frank bauer ist ein beispiel für die die
sagen je mehr druck er ausübt desto
weniger willig ich sehe einige maßnahmen
nicht ein und da ist auch so ein
bisschen so einem trotz dabei manchmal
aber auch das gefühl moment ich
recherchiere hier es gibt noch
krankenhausbetten das müsste doch
eigentlich gehen also dass man so denkt
man kandidaten die davor liegen besser
interpretieren als ist die wissenschaft
tut es gibt aber auch sehr viele die so
aus einem heilpraktiker zum beispiel
sind dann gesundheitliche bedenken haben
gegen impfstoffe generell gegen diesen
noch nicht so erprobten impfstoff ganz
besonders ich habe auch leute gesprochen
die nicht in dem film sind zum beispiel
die longo wird haben die seit einem jahr
leiden darunter dass sie geschwächt sind
und sagen ich würde trotzdem mich nicht
impfen lassen weil wer weiß vielleicht
geht es dann wieder von vorne los es
sind diverse gründe auch auf so einem
anthroposophischen milieu walldorf und
so weiter da ja die welt soll bunt sein
jeder soll nach seiner fasson glücklich
werden und wenn dann ein falls einer
keine maske tragen will sich nicht
impfen lassen will dann ist das ein
ausbrechen aus dem schwarz weiß milde
und dann gibt es natürlich die ganz
harten impfgegner die einfach sagen
lieber stehend sterben als knien leben
das steht tatsächlich auf transparenten
die bei der korona demo in görlitz herum
getragen wurden wo man so eine so ein
gallisches dorf mentalität ist noch zu
schwach ausgedrückt fast aber so eine
generelle also widerstand gegen den
staat gegen die regierenden gegen die da
oben einfach zeigen will dass das sind
so die gründe ja es gibt natürlich auch
leute die in ihrem umfeld von
impfschäden erleben das sind aber die
wenigsten die würde ich noch verstehen
es gibt dann viel glück mit die einfach
gerüchten glauben und die nachplappern
und gar nicht merken wie sich in ihrer
eigenen blase nur noch drehen dass da
jetzt dann tatsächlich schwierig da sind
wir dann am ende der argumente
sind sehr vielfältige gründe du hast sie
trat auch schon aufgezählt werden auch
noch mal im detail da ein bisschen ja
darauf zu sprechen kommen aber jetzt
ganz aktuell wo die instanzen auch so
stark steigen auch während ihr den film
gedreht habt sind sie nach und nach nach
oben geklettert die menschen mit denen
er gesprochen habe da haben die davor
jetzt gar keine angst wenn sie nicht
geimpft sind erstaunlich wenig angst
also die die wir gesprochen haben
glauben an ihre eigenen abwehrkräfte und
sagen auch ich kenne ja niemand ich bin
doch bisher gut durchgekommen die angst
vor einer impfung ist da häufig größer
als die angst tatsächlich gesund zu
bekommen und möglicherweise am langzeit
folgen zu leiden das ist auffällig und
tatsächlich zieht sich das durch was
jetzt noch dazu kommt und was auch in
unserer zeit als wir jetzt gedreht haben
dazu gekommen ist ist das meer im
durchbrüche sind und dadurch fühlen sich
viele
skeptiker hatten natürlich bestätigt
weil sie erst mal sagen naja ihr kriegt
ja auch wenn die wissenschaft dann sagt
ja wir wussten dass eine impfung nicht
vor ansteckung schützt aber vor einem
schweren verlauf das angesprochen es
gibt also zweifel auch an der
wissenschaft und wir haben den
sozialpsychologen
herrn zwick dazu gefragt und hören mal
ganz kurz rein in seiner antwort das
große problem ist dass wir eine immer
wachsende größere gruppe bekommen haben
die das impfen
ideologisiert also nicht als einen
gesundheitsschutz betrachtet auch nicht
als einen schutz für andere menschen
denn unabhängig davon ob mir das impfen
gefällt oder nicht könnte ich ja sagen
na ja gut aus solidarischen gründen last
wie ich mich impfen für andere wie wir
das jetzt am beispiel einer haben in der
bayerischen landesregierung
das alles greift nicht offensichtlich
haben wir menschen die nicht so denken
und insofern haben wir es auch hier mit
einem prozent rasmus zu tun mit einer
verweigerung die damit zusammenhängt
dass die konsequenzen nicht klar sind
sagt
andreas zick von der universität
bielefeld und jetzt sind es nicht nur
die stange ins identen sondern es gibt
ja jetzt auch ganz aktuell vielerorts
der neue zweig regeln auch in bayern und
auch in sachsen wo ihr gedreht habt wie
hat das denn auch dass menschen wie hat
dann hat das dann auch das leben von den
nicht geimpften menschen jetzt verändert
mit denen ihr da gedreht habt in der
doku
in bayern habe ich gehört man fühlt sich
noch mehr ausgeschlossen natürlich und
hat noch weniger verständnis für die
politik weil es wieder mal in den augen
vieler ungeimpfter so eine entscheidung
ist die beweis dass man da
unsinn fabriziert ich zitiere jetzt
indem man sagt ja wenn ihr uns
ausschließt ihr glaubt doch nicht ich
bleibe vielleicht zu hause ich bin 50
aber was machen denn die jungen die
treffen sich halt dann unter dem radar
und das ist doch genau kontraproduktiv
lasst uns doch lieber alle getestet
zusammensein in den restaurants in den
bars die halten diese entscheidungen für
kontraproduktiv in sachsen ist uns
aufgefallen dass die maßnahmen ohnehin
ein bisschen lockerer interpretiert
werden da gibt es zwar auch kontrollen
und es gibt auch die leute die 2g wollen
das ist ja nicht so dass da nur
impfgegner leben aber und im skeptiker
aber tatsächlich hat man das gefühl da
findet man nischen wo man auch ohne
maske oder auch ungeimpft reinkommt weil
man so unter der hand sich versteht also
das ist das ist deutlich dass das wie
ein erkennungszeichen ist schädlich die
hand habe ich die maske richtig auf oder
nicht dann weiß man schon wes geistes
kind an als in sachsen du hast es
angesprochen wo ihr unterwegs wart da
sind auch besonders wenige menschen
geimpft warum ist das so was habt ihr da
festgestellt
nun wir wissen dass teilweise ist
war mit dem wahlverhalten zusammenhängt
wo besonders viel fd gewählt wird ist
die impfskepsis normalerweise sehr hoch
das ist ein grund es ist in sachsen hat
man auch dieses wir gegen die da oben
gefühl schon immer seine trotzige
haltung gegen alles was von außen kommt
was von außen aufgedrückt wird und man
muss auch sehen dass ist da viele
menschen gibt die nie einen vertrauen
zum staat aufgebaut haben zu ddr zeiten
und dann danach ist auch nicht aufgebaut
haben offensichtlich hat das misstrauen
gegenüber dem staat ist dort sehr groß
oder staatlichen institutionen
regelungen die eben von oben kommen und
genau diese dass die ablehnung gegenüber
einer krone impfung auch häufig mit
einer ablehnung gegen staat und politik
ein herkommt danach haben wir auch noch
mal den sozialpsychologen andreas zick
befragt wir haben ja auch gemerkt dass
selbst die konflikt selbst die politik
die regulierung dann soll dann zum teil
in konflikte geraten ist und dort nach
schnellen lösungen gesucht hat dann aber
auch wieder ausgestiegen ist also sie
hat schon die gesellschaft in einen
hohen konflikt hineingezogen und bemesse
ich den gesellschaftlichen frieden daran
dass die gesellschaft möglich gewaltfrei
bleibt haben wir eine anzahl von
vorteils basierten hast taten in der
pandemie wo eigentlich die distanz
größer sein sollte
mit der wir glaube ich so nicht
gerechnet haben die aaa staaten gegen
amt und mandat trägerinnen und träger
gegen wissenschaften jetzt geht es gegen
die ärzte ging im zentrum all das sind
folgen einer eines innere
gesellschaftlichen konfliktes wo es
nicht nur um die pandemie geht sondern
der hochgradig biologie siert worden ist
herzig hat das angesprochen also stehen
sich wirklich so zwei seiten gegenüber
mit teilweise einer ganz harten haltung
patricia deine kollegin sibylle bassler
und du ihr habt auch in krankenhäusern
gedreht mit ärzten gesprochen was habt
ihr da zu spüren bekommen und da auch
gehört eben von den menschen was da
gegeneinander geht und ja wie wie steht
man sich dagegen über
das sind natürlich die die orte wo der
konflikt vielleicht am schärfsten zum
tragen kommt sibylle bassler vor allem
war in vielen vielen intensivstationen
corona stationen unterwegs seit anfang
der pandemie und
interessanterweise gleichen sich die
zustände das ist also kein einzelfall
wenn man da jemanden trifft der hat von
der gerade so überlebt hat und sich
trotzdem nicht impfen lassen würde und
die ärzte und die pflegekräfte sind dort
wirklich am ende es ist schon oft gesagt
worden aber man kann es nicht oft genug
sagen die bemühen sich mit allem was sie
haben und was sie können das leben zu
retten von jedem der da eingeliefert
wird und darunter sind im moment nur
einmal hauptsächlich ungeimpfte die da
auf den intensivstationen landen die
zahlen sprechen da für sich aber auch
die werden von gerona skeptikern eher
angezweifelt
und wenn man dann sieht dass leute sogar
trotz dieser erfahrung
anwohner zweifeln und sich nicht impfen
lassen würden dann ist man wirklich an
stellen wo man sagt ja dann kann man
eigentlich nichts mehr aufbieten was
jemanden noch überzeugen könnte die
ärzte und pflegekräfte machen weiter
sagen uns manchmal 50 überlegen sich
wenn zum beispiel ein physiotherapeut da
eng arbeitet mit einem mit einem kranken
ja manchmal denke ich mir schon hat er
jetzt eigentlich verdient dass ich nicht
da so aufreibend
zu sagen wir haben jetzt mit viel lieber
mit allem was wir können jemanden an der
integration vorbei geschäft und nach
einer woche wird dann gesagt na ja so
schlimm war es ja gar nicht ich lasse
mich nicht impfen und manchmal gibt es
dann sogar einen rückfall und trotzdem
die lage verschlimmert sich wieder der
oder diejenige mustern intubiert werden
und trotzdem ist die impfbereitschaft
nicht da das ist die situation in den
krankenhäusern
wir haben auch genau so einen ton aus
eurer doku von einer corona erkrankten
die sich nicht hat impfen lassen und wir
haben einen ton aus der druck- und hören
ja jetzt auch mal kurz rein
weil ich dem impfstoff nicht vertrauen
alles ging viel zu schnell es gibt keine
langzeitstudie und obwohl ich hier seit
über einer woche liege hat sich an
meiner meinung nichts geändert ich würde
mich nach wie vor nicht impfen lassen
du hast es angesprochen auch zuvor also
da sind dann auch wirklich eben ein
bisschen verhärtete fronten aber die
ärzte reagieren ja dann trotzdem auf
diese menschen und wie finden die
vielleicht auch so einen weg dass man da
auch wieder miteinander sprechen kann
vielleicht gerade auf station aber auch
außerhalb viele haben aufgegeben zu
diskutieren aufgegeben zu überzeugen
weil wenn die fakten nicht für sich
sprechen was soll man da noch sagen
tatsächlich brauchen die ihre kraft für
ihre arbeit und manche sagen sie wollen
jetzt auch nicht mehr reden und können
nicht mehr reden tatsächlich haben viele
das sind ja dann auch noch die argumente
der ungeimpften sagen einfach wir warten
einfach das ist aber noch nicht so lang
erprobt noch nicht genug erprobt und man
fragt dann und die ärzte fragen dann
auch wie wie lange wollen sie denn
warten zehn jahre oder bis wann soll
denn eine impf nebenwirkungen auftreten
dazu sagen das würde man sehr schnell
sehen nach zwei wochen wenn nicht
aufgetreten ist kann es keine impfung
wirkung sein aber man kommt eben schwer
an
gegenargumente die aus ja die in diesem
social media getriebenen diskurs auch
kommen und wo das wesen das argument ist
dass jedes gegenargument das argument
noch stärker macht also man kann sagen
was man will jedes gegenargument dass
man findet produziert nur noch mehr
argumente auf der anderen seite so wird
der graben immer tiefer die mauern auf
beiden seiten immer höher und das ist
das was uns in dieser doku interessiert
hat wie sieht es aus links und rechts
dieses dieser gräben es ist nicht nur
einer dieser risse die da entstehen und
wie gibt es vielleicht möglichkeiten
dann trotzdem im gespräch zu bleiben
nach so einer möglichkeit wie man
vielleicht auch noch miteinander
sprechen kann haben wir auch den
sozialpsychologen andreas zick noch
einmal gefragt
also wenn wir die daten angucken dann
schätzen wir dass wir durchaus noch zehn
überzeugen können wir haben jetzt einige
impfaktionen gesehen wir sehen in einige
städte fahren mit den immobilien dorthin
wo menschen schlecht kommunikation
erhalten wo es besonders prekär ist auch
für menschen da sehen wir jetzt nimmt
das impfen leicht wieder zu wir haben
zwar jetzt noch eine große
herausforderung weil wir auch die
booster impfung noch obendrauf bekommen
denn die wird ja auch empfohlen da sehen
wir etwas wir haben dann beispiele von
besonderen impfaktionen wir sehen
österreich die verschärfung der
kontrollen hat auch nochmal menschen
motiviert wir sehen in der schweiz eine
aktionswoche aus dass also wir können
aus anderen ländern lernen was notwendig
ist und insofern hoffen wir dass wir die
zehn prozent irgendwie noch kriegen
ihr habt eben auch diese frage gestellt
also gibt es da überhaupt noch welche
die sich überzeugen lassen oder
vielleicht wie soll das auch gehen was
waren da die die erfahrung die ihr
gemacht habt
also haben sogar schon mit einem
vorziehen görlitz gesprochen und einem
internisten in seiner praxis impft und
der eine von beiden ist bei einer
infektion für jugendliche dann richtig
hart angegangen worden da stand ein
imbiss skeptiker vor der berufsschule wo
das stattgefunden hat und
haben gesagt sie werden noch ihre
gerechten strafe zugeführt sie töten
kinder und jugendliche wir wissen wo sie
wohnen das sind natürlich
straftaten und da sieht man wie
hoch die aggression dass wir schritt tun
geworden ist wie der umgang miteinander
dieser ab sagt mit solchen leuten hat er
nicht geredet mit solchen leuten kann
man nicht mehr reden er versucht aber
trotzdem und dennoch immer wieder leute
zu überzeugen schafft es auch immer
wieder denn viele werden auch zumindest
in sachsen haben wir das gehört von den
eigenen haus ärzten verunsichert da wird
von hausärzten von der impfung abgeraten
das gibt es also auch die mediziner dort
sind sich nicht sie nicht alle an einem
strang und wenn zum beispiel bei einer
in fortbildung für ärzte eine zweig
regelung eingeführt wird das ist neulich
passiert dann haben gleich mal zehn
prozent der teilnehmer wieder abgesagt
also daran sieht man dann auch das auch
unter medizinern mancher orts die
impfskepsis verbreitet ist und dass sich
das auf die patienten auswirkt die ja
ihrem hausarzt vertrauen das muss man
beim auch verstehen zum ende vielleicht
nimmt man die frage die wir auch ganz am
anfang schon hatten also es gibt aber
auch viele die sich ja sehr sehr
unverstanden fühlen sehr verurteilt
führen von den menschen die jetzt nicht
geimpft sind wie war das denn eigentlich
wie schwierig war das für euch auch
überhaupt menschen zu finden die mit
euch sprechen die sich da so nackt
machen und das auch öffentlich machen
wollen das war eigentlich das
schwierigste an der ganzen sache muss
ich sagen also habe ich so auch noch
nicht erlebt in meinem report erleben
dass leute hemmungen haben wir fordern
von der kamera zu stehen oder dann auch
erstmal
kamera fries wie man es nennt so haben
das kommt vor aber dass leute frei reden
am telefon und sich auch in blogs und im
internet aus dem fenster lehnen aber
dann nicht vor der kamera wollen auf gar
keinen fall oder wenn sie selber tun
dann keiner im umfeld mehr zu finden ist
aus dem freundes familienkreis
bekanntenkreis war schon sehr auffällig
wir mussten das her
man sieht im grunde die spitze des
eisbergs in unserer doku mit mit
ungefähr zehnmal so vielen leuten haben
wir geredet die nicht vor die kamera
wollten und ich muss sagen ich spreche
meine bewunderung aus allen die es doch
getan haben denn jeder der sich aus dem
fenster lehnt in dieser art und position
bezieht in der impf debatte riskiert
einen shitstorm auch die experten im
übrigen die selbst bedroht werden und
schon beängstigende situationen
erlebt haben auch wenn sie nur
forschungsergebnisse veröffentlicht
haben als psychologin oder als soziologe
und diese spannende doku gibt es heute
abend im tv und wie gesagt jetzt schon
in der mediathek geimpft oder nicht
kleine kleine frage große sprengkraft so
heißt es von patricia schäfer und
sibylle bassler danke patricia für den
moment dank alice
und wir haben jetzt noch zeit viele von
euren fragen zu besprechen und auch
gerade viele von den kritischen fragen
mit der virologe professor ulrike
protzer von der technischen universität
münchen
denn viele ungeimpfte fühlen sich mit
den zugelassenen impfstoffen nicht wohl
das habe ich schon in den kommentaren
auch gelesen und jetzt haben wir also
die möglichkeit über alle fragen in
sachen impfstoff zu sprechen und ich
hoffe dass wir frau professor protzer
auch gleich sehen können da ist hier
schon guten abend frau protzer
hallo da vielleicht direkt die erste
frage ich hab's angesprochen viele sagen
sie fühlen sich also mit den aktuell
zugelassenen impfstoffe nicht wohl das
ging manchen zu schnell in der zulassung
was ist ihre antwort darauf
ganz am anfang ganz ehrlich hätte ich
das verstanden weil da waren ja wirklich
nur die studienergebnisse da mit beiden
studien jetzt von den mrsa studien je
40.000 menschen die apotheker studien
bisher weniger aber nicht zwischenzeit
haben wir doch wirklich sehr sehr viele
daten
wir haben weltweit 7,5 milliarden
menschen inzwischen geimpft etwa eine
milliarde im system die wirklich hoch
reguliert sind wo wir jede nebenwirkung
uns anschauen und da denke ich mir so
ein bisschen gut eine größere datenbasis
dafür dass die impfstoffe sicher sind
gibt es ja nicht und sicher das muss man
einfach immer sagen heißt nie 100
prozent aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ich eine schwere impfnebenwirkungen
bekomme ist wirklich wirklich selten die
ist so in dem bereich ja dass ich vom
blitz getroffen werde in etwa und das
ist einfach extrem unwahrscheinlich was
auch häufig kommt sind fragen zur
langzeit folgen da habe ich auch eine
bei uns bei youtube gesehen von speed
schiller sie fragt oder er fragt wo
bleiben die daten zu longo wird ohne die
daten kann man nicht nachrechnen wie man
in meiner altersgruppe 25 scheint die
person zu sein statistisch besser dran
steht bei einer sterberate von 0,01 ohne
impfung ganz zu schweigen davon dass ich
keiner risikogruppe angehöre die frage
ist wo bleiben die daten zu longo wird
was ja eine
was ja aber eines muss kurz mal klar
machen das wäre ja natürlich eine eine
folge einer kur wird erkrankung also
vielleicht müssen wir das in zwei fragen
spalten also erst mal wo bleiben die
daten zur longo wird fragt bachelor
ich kann die frage gut verstehen und ich
finde sie auch sehr berechtigt wenn
jemand der junge ist sagt na ja wenn ich
mich jetzt impfen lasse dann ist es für
mich persönlicher gar nicht so ein
großer schutz weil setzt wenn ich mich
infizieren ein risiko schwer krank zu
werden gering ist dem kann man da nur
antworten das ist schon richtig dass ist
gering aber es ist auch nicht null und
es ist immer noch ein ganzes stück höher
als das risiko einer impfung da gibt es
inzwischen auch beim also wahnsinnig die
leben hat sehr gute daten dazu wo man
ganz genau geschaut wo ist denn das
risiko nach der impfung höher und höher
ist das risiko nach der infektion höher
und das einzige wofür das risiko nach
der info höher ist ist eine
lymphknotenschwellung zu entwickeln das
muss man auch ganz klar sagen alle
anderen dinge sind immer noch das risiko
nach einer infektion höher trotzdem kann
ich standpunkt verstehen und viele junge
menschen argumentieren natürlich so dass
sie dann kommt mein persönliches risiko
ist gering
manche sagen ich habe jetzt niveau ist
oder ich sehe eine gesellschaftliche
verpflichtung weil ich möchte natürlich
diejenigen die jetzt ein höheres risiko
haben mit schützen dass es die zweite ja
der zweite grund natürlich warum man
sich impfen lassen sollten eben jetzt
den persönlichen risiko aber wenn man
jetzt wissen möchte außer der akuten
infektion das besteht denn für ein long
cobit risiko haben wir in deutschland
tatsächlich keine guten zahlen ich
persönlich schaue mir dann immer die
zahlen aus england an da gibt es zum
glück gute zahlen und ich gehe mal davon
aus dass england dass er ähnlich sind
die deutsche da gibt es eine sehr große
evolution mit über 200.000 menschen in
jeder gruppe und die vergleicht menschen
die kobik 19 gehabt haben und menschen
die kurven 19 nicht gehabt haben und
schaut dann nach den sogenannten longo
wird folgen ist total wichtig diese
kontrollgruppe zu haben weil viele der
symptome sind doch ein bisschen
unspezifisch und wenn man da rein schaut
dann sieht man dass die gruppe
derjenigen die über 17 jahre alt ist ein
doch erhöhtes risiko für long cobit hat
und der steigt mit zunehmendem alter bis
so etwa 70 jahre an und es ist bei
frauen deutlich höher als es bei männern
ist also wer das als argument für sich
benutzen möchte um sich selber auch zu
überzeugen da ist es schon wert mal in
so eine datenbasis hineinzuschauen und
dann aber auch noch einmal die frage
nach den langzeitfolgen vor denen sich
viele sorgen die eben noch nicht geimpft
sind
ich kann natürlich über
die folgen über eine zeit nur etwas
sagen solange ich auch die
langzeitbeobachtung habe es lange ich
das weiss man
weiß aus der entwicklung von ganz ganz
vielen impfstoffen wie man ja über die
jahrzehnte gemacht hat dass
langzeitfolgen von impfstoffen in
der regel innerhalb von zwei wochen
auftreten aber bis spätestens zwei
monate nach der impfung auftreten
deswegen hat man auch schon bei den
initialen studien gesagt stopp
keine zulassung nach weniger als zwei
monaten sondern wir möchten bitte drei
monate nach beobachtungszeit um zu
wissen kommt da noch irgendwas da ist
nichts gekommen und die zahl der vielen
geimpften ja jetzt auch schon seit einem
jahr hat auch da gibt es keinen hinweis
dass irgendetwas
nachgekommen wäre an
langzeiteffekte insofern glaube ich mit
jedem jahr mit eben geimpften und mit
jedem monat länger zeit haben werden wir
da natürlich auch immer noch sicherer
was ich jetzt häufig in den kommentaren
gelesen habe gerade von menschen die
jetzt die jünger sind dann möchte ich
mal einen kommentar stellvertretend
vorlesen ferry die bei youtube möchte
wissen warum sollte man sich als
21-jähriger kerngesunder mensch der sich
regelmäßig testet impfen lassen wenn man
durch die tests die anderen menschen
mehr schützt
das ist wieder so ein bisschen das
argument was wir gerade auch schon
hatten wenn ich für mich persönlich
keine hohe gefährdung sehe warum soll
ich das tun ich nehme da mal ganz gerne
das beispiel des sicherheitsgurtes im
auto ist ihren sicherheitsgurt im auto
auch deshalb an weil
ich wenn ich dann einen unfall haben
sollte indem ich mich schwerer verletzen
könnte geschützt bin das heißt noch
nicht dass ich diesen unfall habe oder
ihn vielleicht wahrscheinlicher habe
weil ich weil ich den sicherheitsgurt
trage sondern ich möchte mich für diese
situation einfach besser vorbereiten und
da geht es wirklich nur um einen
eigenschutz da geht es nicht um den
schutz anderer menschen dem ich jetzt
bei einer impfung noch als als
nebeneffekt habe im auto der
sicherheitsgurt er kann mich auch
verletzt es besteht die möglichkeit
genauso selten wie die bg nebenwirkungen
oder schweren nebenwirkungen einer
impfung besteht die möglichkeit dass
sich durch das tragen eines
sicherheitsgurtes verletzt werde
trotzdem tragen wir alle sicherheitsgurt
weil wir sagen das schützt uns eben für
den fall wo wir mal einen schweren und
wann haben sollten und wenn wir auf die
intensivstationen schauen und unsere
erfahrung aus den verschiedenen wellen
die erste welle und jetzt gerade auch
wieder die kältewelle sind halt schon
leider auch junge menschen die das
trifft das ist viel seltener als ältere
menschen aber es liegt da auch eben der
35-jährige skitourengeher mit familie wo
man sagt bohr den hec eigentlich nie
treffen dürfen rein statistisch gesehen
treffen tut es ihm aber doch da muss
jeder für sich natürlich so ein bisschen
selber entscheiden der eigenschutz ist
durch test 0 gegeben der schutz für an
dabei bin kann ich natürlich auch durchs
testen deutlich verbessern
und es gibt viele imker kritische
menschen also auf jeden fall menschen
die jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind die
sagen sie wollten wollen auf einen
sogenannten tod impfstoff warten zum
beispiel von nowaks die heute die eu
zulassung beantragt haben das dauert
aber dann noch eine weile hier auch nur
stellvertretend schreibt jason bei
youtube zdf kannst du mal sagen wann der
tod impfstoff kommt vielleicht damals
ihre einschätzung zu diesem sogenannten
tod impfstoff
also
dürfen von proteinen basierter impfstoff
es ist auch kein ganz klassischer tod
impfstoff mit klassischem stoff wäre
wenn ich das virus an züchter und dann
ab tötete und dann impfe diesen staffel
gibt es in china die funktionieren aber
leider sehr sehr schlecht deswegen würde
ich die überhaupt nicht in erwägung
ziehen dieser nowaks impfstoff ist ein
proteinbasierter ein klassischer
impfstoff der das protein in so kleinen
nano partikel gepackt hat damit es eben
sehr gut wirkt und der ist tatsächlich
nach der studie genauso wirksam wie die
m r stoppen nämlich zu 95 prozent also
das ist sicherlich ein sehr guter im
stoff und eine alternative für
diejenigen die sagen das konzept der
marina im stoff gefällt mir nicht so gut
ich möchte lieber zum klassischen
proteine im stoff haben der aber dann
natürlich auch wirksam sein sollte und
es ist dieser impfstoff allen studien
zufolge wenn man über breite erfahrungen
nachdenkt ist es natürlich so dass jetzt
die em-arena im staffel schon viel mehr
eingesetzt sind das heißt da wird viel
mehr und auch mehr erfahrung als mit dem
nowak ist im stoff trotzdem ist das sehr
bewährtes sehr gutes konzept und stellt
sicherlich für diejenigen die jetzt mit
dem gedanken er im stoff sich nicht
anfreunden können einfach eine gute
alternative dar wann der kommt das weiß
ich auch nicht der ist im rolling review
also wohl immer wieder daten angeschaut
werden bei der ema seit februar
die zulassung ist jetzt beantragt worden
das ist so ein paar wochen her ich hoffe
mal dass er vor weihnachten noch kommt
aber da stecke ich natürlich auch nicht
dass ich auch noch häufiger gelesen habe
war eine gewisse skepsis wegen der impf
durchbrüche die es gab da ist juri
gagarin auf youtube mit einer frage
vertreten der sagt wie erklärt man
schließlich die hohen fallzahlen in
ländern mit sehr hoher impfquote wenn
mit impfungen die fallzahlen höher sind
als zu zeiten ohne impfung worum worin
liegt dann der nutzen der impfung
also das hängt natürlich einmal davon ab
welches virus ist gerade unterwegs sie
ansteckend ist dass und wie hoch ist die
das infektionsgeschehen insgesamt und
davon hängt dann auch wie viele menschen
infizieren sich ist infizieren sich
überall auf der welt mehr als geimpfte
ein proportional gesehen das ist glaube
ich unstrittig und wenn man mal anschaut
wo ist viel infektionsgeschehen und wo
es wenig infektionsgeschehen dann ist es
genau konträr zu dem wie geimpft wird
also länder mit sehr hohen importen
nehmen sie spanien als beispiel nehmen
sie portugal als beispiel wir haben sehr
niedrige infektionszahlen länder mit
niedrigeren quoten haben deutlich höhere
infektionszahlen und wenn damit ganz
niedrigen quoten haben sehr hohe
infektionszahlen aber die ihn von mir es
ja nicht das einzige
da fängt darf spielen natürlich immer
auch andere faktoren mit hinein das
heißt welche schutzmaßnahmen werden
gerade in dem jeweiligen land angewendet
gibt es kontakt reduktionen gibt es
keine gibt es dermaßen pflicht gibt es
keine das alles spielt in die in das
infektionsgeschehen mit rein aber diese
korrelation in ähnlichen bereichen ist
schon sehr klar ich habe gerade von den
wissenschaftlern der analyse gesehen hat
dass mal die bundesländer auf gegliedert
und das ist tatsächlich so
diejenigen gene hohe importe haben das
sind ja so die länder im bundesländer im
nordwesten deutschlands die haben
deutlich weniger infektionen als
diejenigen die jetzt eher im osten oder
im süden liegen wo die impfquoten
niedriger sind also eine umgekehrte
korrelation gibt es da ganz eindeutig es
gibt noch mehr
skeptische kritische fragen frau
professor protzer deswegen umso besser
dass sie heute hier bei uns in der
sendung sind ich möchte noch einen davon
aufgreifen und zwar von fred clever bei
youtube er schreibt es wird ja immer von
sicherheit gesprochen und nun wurde
angeordnet dass unter 30 jährigen nur
noch mit bayern tag geimpft werden heißt
das nicht dass monatelang falsch geimpft
wurde hätte sowas nicht vor der
zulassung der anderen impfstoffe klar
sein müssen dass
ist dass die krux mit selteneren
nebenwirkungen bei einer
zulassungsstudie sind 40.000 menschen
aufgenommen worden wenn ich jetzt eine
nebenwirkung habe die ist seltener als 1
zu 40.000 dann sehe ich die statistisch
nicht da brauche ich dann ein paar
hunderttausend dazu und dann gibt es
auch nebenwirkungen die sind einfach
noch seltener und die sehe ich erst dann
wenn ich eine noch größere gruppe also
vielleicht mal eine million oder auch
zehn millionen games habe und genau so
ist es jetzt gewesen man hat gesehen
dass durch die vermutlich durch die
höhere dosis der mrta in den moderner
impfstoff ersten dort bei jungen
menschen die burka geht es etwas
häufiger ist als bei den bio entdeckten
stoff wie ist insgesamt immer noch sehr
selten sie ist viel seltener als nach
der infektion das ist auch wichtig zu
wissen sie verläuft meist gut aber wenn
ich dann zwei alternativen habe man
nehme ich natürlich diejenigen die
weniger probleme bereitet auch wenn es
seltener probleme sind und diese
entscheidung ist in den fall zu gefallen
dass man gesagt hat okay bei montech
macht es einfach seltener als moderner
das macht und deswegen geht noch bis
zum schluss noch eine frage frau protz
wir hatten es schon angesprochen es hat
viele auch interessiert wenn denn dieser
sogenannte tod impfstoff käme fragt
matze auf youtube wie hoch ist der
schutz gegen delta bald nowaks damit
nennt er einen hersteller
es gibt im moment auch nur den nowaks
hersteller der sozusagen jetzt gerade in
der in der zulassung ist
die studien sind mit dem mit der alpha
variante begonnen worden und sind jetzt
in wie delta variante fortgesetzt worden
und der schutz ich habe die finalen
daten auch noch nicht gesehen weil sich
kompliziert sind bisher scheint auch bei
der delta variante weiterhin über 90% zu
sein also das ist immer noch ein sehr
wirksamer impfstoff
alle impfstoffe alles was wir bisher
machen es war delta etwas weniger
wirksam aber das heißt ich dass es
gleich nicht mehr wirksam ist sondern
der abstand ist halt so ein paar prozent
jeweils und insofern denke ich ist es
immer noch eine gute alternative auch
wenn wir jetzt delta haben und das wäre
wäre ich - wenn
ich hab doch noch eine frage an sie zum
schluss das hat sich dann doch noch hier
was angesammelt es gibt nämlich dann
durch mehrere bemerkungen jetzt auch in
sachen booster impfung das ist ja was
was hier vielleicht jetzt eben auf
mehrere sehr viele menschen zukommt also
wie normal ist das vielleicht dass man
einfach mehrere impfungen brauch bei
einem impfstoff weil sich viele jetzt
wundern dass man also jetzt noch mal ein
muster brauch das gerne noch zum schluss
also dass sich eine dritte impfung
brauche etwas was ihnen jetzt bei
impfstoffen eher normal ist wenn ich mir
andere impfstoffe anschauen wenn ich mit
tetanus anschauen wenn ich eine folie
anschaue bin ich mir kosten anschauen
wenn ich eine hepatitis b anschauen ich
brauche immer drei impfungen warum weil
ich mit der ersten impfung bereit ich
mein immunsystem vor da habe ich noch
kaum effekt bei der zweiten impfung
reagiert mein immunsystem dann aber erst
der dritte impfung und die muss dann
tatsächlich gewissen abstand erfolgen
das macht man halt so bei fast allen
impfungen etwa nach sechs monaten oder
vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen
länger da werden die gedächtniszellen
dann noch mal daran erinnert dass da
etwas ist auch was sie besonders
aufpassen müssen also mich wundert es
überhaupt nicht dass werden die impfung
brauchen
wir wissen das ja auch schon seit einer
weile da gibt es ja aus und mehreren
ländern inzwischen schon ganz gute
studien jetzt auch für diese ascona
virusimpfstoffe wissens auch aus der
erfahrung von vielen anderen impfstoffen
dass es notwendig ist
vielen dank frau professor ulrike
protzer virologin an der technischen
universität münchen dass sie sich so
viel zeit jetzt für all diese fragen
heute abend genommen haben vielen dank
und natürlich wie immer auch danke an
euch dass ihr so viele fragen gestellt
habt und zugeschaut habt und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder bis dahin danke und
tschüss